all right what are your names
Shane Stifler I'm Kelly Stifler
right yeah and you guys Michigan young
Detroit wait outside Detroit in the
house again
and you're out here at zero yeah oh you
been here 30 days know a little bit
about those are pretty crazy
sirens whoa bad sense yeah like every
five minutes
yeah just never seen stuff like this I
mean we have worse I'd say just not as
fast paced slower it's more
yeah like slow movement slow motion nice
yeah more discrete this happen or not
here all day yeah it's busy here it's
fast
so tell me but you didn't say you pack
see when you were a kid Shane you were
with you my my mom my dad were together
until I was what we were about four I
was about four and then my mom got
addicted to crack cocaine and left
and then my my brothers and sisters went
to foster homes I went to my grandma's
my other brother went to a friend of the
family and then my dad what's a prison
and I stayed with my grandma for the
laws about its well and then my dad
ended up getting me and my younger
brother Kevin back on all of us there's
nine of us me and my brother Kevin a my
brother Jason he was uh it wasn't my
dad's but my dad raised him as his own
until he was about 13 so he was too you
know too hard to handle and a friend of
the family adopted him and we me and my
brother stayed with my dad for the
majority of the time but he was a real
bad alcoholic and you know beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of us every day and we
were you know we allowed to do whatever
there was no rules there was no you know
we raised herself you know I mean I
raised my little brother so anything
that I was getting into 12 11 13 14 he
was doing at 7 and 8 so he he got
exposed to some [ __ ] Wade earlier than I
did you know there's either he's he's in
Michigan he's done
three-count or he's gone three sets in
prison already days 20 was he 27 or 28
he was in prison 27 he was in prison
about time when he was 17 he did three
he's doing three three sets already he's
done Friday [ __ ] most half of his life
in juvie and and in and out of prison
and yeah he was he's like five - so he's
got little man syndrome and it just he'd
fight the biggest dude in the world man
you know he just use
he's our door and you know I I'm
probably the one to blame you know I
mean for exposing them to everything you
know I mean I just if I did it he was
right there with me you know my name is
Kelly Kevin so tell me what you - where
were you at this time you were smoking
crack in your on the street yeah so you
have two kids with their dad yeah no
never went to prison so I was present
three times so I was after the first
time after when I really got addicted
when I first got a date it's a person I
might smoke it but my brother's funding
copy that started on app and then I used
to be totally against drugs and then I
see my brothers and my uh my brother's
doing having cocaine parties and just
people everywhere and you know I mean
then just doing lines and doing lines
and I was pregnant and I was like I
don't want to do it and they just kept
doing line to a line just do it and I'm
like [ __ ] it I'll do it and then my
brother Billy come over and cooked we
were doing lines and he I went to the
bathroom and he said never and I come
out and then my focus all my cooks in
the microwave he's pumping it up they
can crack out
and I'm like what's up what're you doing
and then he's like it's wait until it's
done you're gonna love it and then he
puts him in the pipe and then he hands
it to me and I blow out a cloud and I
just throw the fight back if I'm like I
don't walk and feel not they're not and
he's like let me do it for you and then
he showed me how to you know I mean or
the pipe and hit it and yeah so uh yeah
I've been clean for from that for four
years it would be four years in June
from crack yes that face of you is
working I don't I do black yeah everyone
that's always been like my drug of
choice I go on and off like I not like I
I got like I don't [ __ ] crazy I I can
achieve so much in life and I can do so
good and I can i yeah I've had five
fortunes and squandered them all you
know what I mean like I get to where I
have a house and cars and money and you
know and and then I just get bored you
know what I mean you know like and I
[ __ ] and that's when I'm clean
I you know I put my you know I put my
feet to the ground and I not buckle in
and I get a job and I start saving
everything and I started doing really
good and I get a house and I get cars
and I get motorcycles and I get money in
the bank and then I get complacent I get
I get tired of just being a slave is
totally different people
yeah I you know I like I just I start to
get bored so then I'm like you know
living paycheck to paycheck I have all
these nice things and everything's going
really good but in the back of my mind
I'm just bored you know what I mean I'm
just like [ __ ] what am I doing this for
you know what I mean I'm working every
day just to you know come home eat [ __ ]
go to work eat sleep [ __ ] go you know
what I mean it's just it's routine and
routine the routine and it gets it gets
old so I [ __ ] they're all forking the
cog and mess it all up
I'll start selling drugs again and going
back to that you know when he styles
drugs he saw
you don't eat playing no I you know like
I I go to the you know I just take it to
the extreme I go to the fullest I make
thousands of dollars and you know but
then that comes with uh with the tech
you know I always got a gun on me and
I'm always II you know if you're not
certain
I've always sold cocaine and you know
I'd stay up for days and then stormily
Pelican [ __ ] go crazy do and you know
shooting at people and sticking guns in
people's faces and running from the cops
and not end up in jail and then [ __ ]
you know or not you you know I finally
get out and I lose my apartment and then
I'd be living in one of my cars and I'd
sell it get ring it and then I'd be
right back on the street again and sell
everything and then I'm like [ __ ] you
know I start shooting heroin again you
know I mean that numb at all so they're
not you know and I'll be homeless on the
street and then I do everyone for about
six seven eight months and then until I
got to where I was bored with that and
sick of that and then I clean up and
[ __ ] go get a job start saving money
go go to apartment give it a chance this
last time though he got out he swore up
and down he wasn't gonna do it as soon
as he got out
not even like why he tried to hide it
from me but I knew I know I stayed maybe
a week my childhood was your childhood
back my hope when my childhood my mom
died when I was seven I have nine older
brothers and sisters I'm the baby then
when my mom died
I was seven years old and then my family
my brothers and sisters were like push
me away and
little baby says there you know it's
like I raised myself since I was seven
my dad turned into an alcoholic and he
couldn't deal with my mom's death and
then he he tried to kill herself a few
times and I would come home from school
and find him
country music would be blaring and and
he would be passed out on the floor and
all his pills would be laying next to
him and his friends would all be there
and it was just a bad scene my mom's
pictures laying all around the house you
know and and then I could just run I did
I come in and I never want to go home
hours I ask my friends if I could come
home with them after school and then you
know and then cause I did he never
wanted to go home because I knew I was
coming home too and then when I was
probably about 14 that's when I started
being bad and rebelling and you know
what I mean just I was they called me
roadrunner and then my nobody in my
family really liked me didn't he might
have cared about me a but they just like
you know Kelly yeah I'm the black sheep
of the family and and I had nine kids
and not custody of any of them and then
the crack game and
correct really took it away for me and
you know and it I was just out there and
I mean bad prostituting and everything
and I never said that in front of my son
before it's embarrassing
I'm sure he knows and but I was bad I'm
really really bad I was weighed like 98
pounds and I guess I wouldn't go home it
was mean like Christmas and like the
holidays in the Easter and I would just
I remember just like sitting in a park
by myself and just crying and you know
wishing I was at home you know with my
family do you see a connection between
your childhood and the way you ended up
and then your children's absolutely yeah
and I hate it you know I mean we get
high together and you don't even did
some people say like oh you're the best
mom and I'm like really not you know I
suck at being a mom but they're like
well my mom's a [ __ ] and she would
never you know let me get a high where
we never got high together but I mean
it's it's not a good thing he's gonna do
what he wants every day at least I get
to be with him you know
and we've been together every day for
like the past what three two years yeah
yeah we had a bhoot today so work down
this way now I moved to Oregon and I met
a girl in Detroit I was homeless I just
got out of jail he was homeless and met
a girl online and you know told her
everything about my life and she was
like well [ __ ] you can come stay with me
I moved in with her and our friend and
we started going to Detroit and I kept
looking going back to Toledo and selling
it and started getting started smoking
crack and stuff together and and I was
clean off heroin I wasn't doing heroin
and
like after about six months of us
staying at her friend's house she kept a
job and she comes from a really wealthy
family and I didn't know this at the
time she always kept that a secret and
she always kept a job and she worked
with everything to her but when she'd
come home we could getting high and
everything and then um her friend found
out that we were she found a crack pipe
in the room and found out we were
smoking and we just basically told her
everything you know I mean I had more
inside of Michigan and warrants out of
Ohio so I was running from the law and
I'm like [ __ ] it dude let's just pack
the car with everything we got and we
found we went to the bar that night and
we found 50 oxy 30 oxy or no perc
thirties somebody had dropped a bag I
think there was 51 of them in there
Kirk 30s and in Detroit they go for $30
pop so I sold all over 1,700 so we had
some some money you know it means
something like what this is perfect you
know what I mean you can pack the car
and get on the road and we were just
called her friends in Texas and we were
planning on going to Texas and living
with her friends in Texas and we get off
to Texas and there's nowhere for us to
stay we're living in the tent they came
to me it was hot as hell she had some
warrants in Michigan so she went to
Florida and staying with her niece and
then met this guy I'm lying and moved in
with him so we didn't have nowhere to go
me and my girl so we're like screw it
let's go you know stay with mom I said
we could go there and stay in Florida so
we drove over to Florida his house was
trash and this house was so disgusting
in there I had to make him redo the
whole house and everything and stunk so
bad I haven't yet seven pit bulls and
half of them had mange so bad I didn't
have a hair on there
body I want soon I walked in the house
I'm like where's the back door that's
what I said I walk straight outside was
like my own I'm sorry I can't do it dude
I can't take that smell I couldn't even
eat food in the house it was so bad we
might be on the street but it's still
clink I'd still got to be clean yet I
mean it's still gonna have that so
wonder where she's gonna live it's a
wonder I'm still alive I know laughs not
doing drugs doing drugs doing drugs
drugs drugs used to saying every time
having a mom and our but you know I
having a mom and dad that's got a lot to
do because of the pain
you got pain you got pain it keeps it
away and the drugs take the pain away
you're doing them saying that's why I
would always I got eight kids myself
eight kids and a granddaughter I have
not yet enrolled a daughter he didn't
but a five baby momma's baby and I you
know I had my first wife I uh we were
together we had identical twins then we
had two more daughters and life was
amazing we had a nice house with cars I
was working I was working to a
construction I'm a journeyman carpenter
you know I was making 26 dollars an hour
coming home you know with the family you
had my boys had my girls and everything
was cool and I've been doing tattoos
since I was like 13 is just like a
little side hustle and you know I like
I'm really good I don't know I know
and a professional tattoo artist for
like ten years now but I I set up a shop
in my apartment and my my wife just had
the twins and she ran out of her
percocets and she had a c-section on her
stomach and she ran over her pills or
something laying on the couch and she
was crying and she's hurt and she's like
oh you know I'm in pain I'm in pain what
can you do for me I'm like either that
baby there anything I can do and I just
happened to be tattooing this Mexican
kid and he's like bro I got some heroin
you know what I'm saying I'm like well
my brother does heroin he says it's like
opiates it's the same thing as pills you
know I'm saying I'm like well babe you
could do a line of this you know this
heroin and you know it make you feel
better so she does a line I'm like [ __ ]
it I'll do a line too so he ends up
living across the hall you know I'm
saying so now there's a [ __ ] drug
dealer that lives across the first time
ever did heroin and 20 minutes later
she's out she's cleaning she feels good
she's like you're not feel amazing and I
finished this tattoo and the tattoo just
comes out flawlessly you know I mean
because I could slow down and I couldn't
so I started using that as an excuse to
I'm about to go do a tattoo I'm gonna go
get a 22nd oh you know what it means so
I could do this tattoo really good I
could call him down slow down
she was right oh right and then yeah
Jason my older brother was a heroin
addict and he always told me that if you
[ __ ] snort it you're wasting it so I
just immediately he was like I'm going
to get a bag of Riggs I started to know
within six months I had lost my job I
had lost the apartment me and the twins
and the two girls and my girl were
living out of my car and then we're
living I'm doing tattoos in Detroit at
the dope man's house and we're living
with four kids at dope man's house and
paying for rent and our drug habit with
me doing tattoos so I'm staying up all
day all night tattooing everybody that
comes over the house I'm trading don't
for work or whatever and eventually my
sister called me and was like hey dude
you guys are in a bad place let me take
the kids you know
so you guys ain't got the kids in this
you know in this environment and
everything and I'm like alright so I
give I give her the kids and then well
at me I fought you know I ended up like
we ended up moving into this other house
this old lady was she was real - she's
like 7 years old but her daughter we had
went over there to do a tattoo cuz me
and it's about the tattoo and her
daughter was shooting her up with heroin
getting her to spend all our SSI money
on crack and just like extorting her mom
you know what I mean and I was just like
man this is [ __ ] up you know what I
mean so I'm like I'll take her to the
room and I'm like you've your daughter's
doing your dirty dude like you know with
Robyn or taking all her money taking her
gold rings and [ __ ] and I'm like you
need to kick that girl out doing and let
me and my girl come and move in who will
take care of you you know what I mean
like I might be a drug addict I'm a
piece of [ __ ] but I'm still I still
respect my elders you know I mean I'm
like this you know moment so I clean the
house and I'm paying her bills with her
car making sure you know what I'm saying
she has a place to stay you know and she
passed away while we was living there
I came home one day and II know she well
I mean I don't know I don't know I just
we came home and she was on the floor
and she had passed away you know she was
dead my broken broke in the house and
called an ambulance and we stayed in the
house for about a month after she had
passed away until a landlord came and
kicked us out and everything and then I
was just I was so fed up with it I'm
like I'm getting clean doing them I'm
done I laid in bed 17 days at worst
worst detox ever went through my like 17
days to kick in heroin and it was fat
and all it was it was Detroit dope so it
was the best open the world you know one
pack it killed somebody I was doing 25
packs and a shot what check I would put
I'll go by two bundles 200 200 bucks I
get I get 26 packs
I'll put them all in the spoon Wow and I
take someone to Detroit with me and they
get one pack one pack ten dollar packs
and do one and be folded be in the
backseat couple my friends that died off
one pack
still alive and I'd put 24 of them in
the spoon do it and don't load it up and
my friends would be like what do you go
and do Wow
you're gonna kill yourself bro and I'm
late you sound crazy do and boom and I'd
do it and what do you give you hunt
wouldn't even I got cleaning from that I
walk away from straight from doing two
two bundles in a shot right on my own
yeah cold turkey
seven the worst detox I ever did in my
life and I laid in bed and I did it on
top of my girl having the same habit
with me and I was strong enough to fight
for both of us you know it means she
laid there right there next to me and it
uses she was using just as much as I was
and you stopped she quit and I said
you're quitting - oh she could only she
quit as she had no other choice so and
what was crazy is my bill my dope dealer
lived right up right above us so at any
point in time I mean it was to the point
to where we were puking up one and just
I mean it was it was we didn't sleep for
17 days that's why I say what's the 17
day detox because the 17th day I finally
got a couple hours of sleep so we were
just fighting fighting analogies I just
I took heroin and I just looked at it
like I hate you you know what I mean and
I you know we just get any time I got an
urge or any you know what I mean the
urge never left but I would just escape
I would just get pissed and be like [ __ ]
[ __ ] you heroin I'm done I'm done and
I'd cry like we'd be praying to God and
doing whatever we could just to fight it
another day and we finally did it we she
moved to Toledo I got a job in Detroit
on a nine-mile doing a hardwood floors
with my my buddy Spencer and we stayed
clean for me and him he was kicking he
kicked heroin too we had met in jail and
then I had ran back him so when we got a
job and we were
concerts and we were going to festivals
and you know we were messing around and
then um he died he passed away he ended
up going to a rehab he wanted that
though the whole time we were in Detroit
we were doing ecstasy and cocaine and
stuff like that but we stayed away from
heroin he wanted to go back to this
rehab that he was in in Toledo because
he was the manager of the house and he
you know he liked it he said he really
he liked that atmosphere and helping
people and Zach even I think I'm gonna
go back to this rehab and and and Toledo
you should come with me and I'm like I'm
out I'll go to Toledo with you and I got
hooked back up with my ex-wife and when
I got back to Toledo I was clean for the
whole eight nine months that we are
working in Detroit and he went to the
halfway house I got hooked up in the ex
with my wife that I had this ones with
and she was strung out and I immediately
started using again you know what I mean
we got in his family house program to
try to get our kids back and and I ended
up going to jail for a stolen truck that
we were riding around in and I had hit a
lick at Walmart and was doing I was
boosting every day I was stealing like
[ __ ] I was that I had five different
Walmart's press five felony charges on
me in five different counties so I had
five all marks looking for me they were
posting my picture on Facebook I
couldn't catch me stealing D I would
walk in and I put 500 blu-ray DVDs in a
cart and push it out
when thirty dollars of Pop was like 20
grand and DVDs every day I pushed out of
their store and not get away with it and
I was selling them they revs and Toledo
and making like thousand dollars a day
just boost and we have enough my homeboy
town albums and and you know we've
checked into this family house place a
program to help us get our kids back
when we started we got clean and we
started doing programs and she got on a
drug court and I always doing my
probation we were doing
we got a house we got a car back we got
jobs we started get our kids on the
weekends and then she had one week of
drug court to do right and drug courts a
hard program to complete and she
completed everything and I was so proud
of her dude and I stayed clean this
whole time and she ended up dropping
dirty for the last week of joke or so
she [ __ ] it up for us walked
everything out so in despite of you know
my caseworker was I dude you're done you
know your kids are gone they're getting
adopted your sister now if you want to
go and try to take and fight for the
kids or gonna have to divorce Amanda
you're gonna have to do all the courses
back again and I was just I was so you
know my kids were everything to me good
my boys man or everything to me so I
just it hurts so bad that I I'd have to
leave my wife you know what I'm saying
so I'm just like you I look at it I'm
like you know what doing you did this
[ __ ] dude I'm going to get a 22nd oh you
know what I mean and I'm gonna hit it
and she was like long we got this house
that we were fighting so hard for and
now we got this house and all our kids
[ __ ] in there and then their kids are
gone you know what I mean so like that
just that pain I just I was trying to
kill myself you know I mean I was doing
above and beyond that I'm not a heroin I
should have did and that was just boom
home doings you know ended up getting
raided for selling dope bought the house
and I go to jail for nine days she goes
to jail for nine days we both get help
we come back to the house and I'm like
I'm done no no no I'm not touching this
[ __ ] no more do with also her kids we're
gonna lose this house this is for
nothing you know what I'm saying what
the [ __ ] is the point we got nine days
clean and she's like all right I am 11
dollars in my pocket and I'm like I'm
gonna go to the bar and I'm gonna have a
beer so I'll go to the bar
and she's like let me see that $10 dude
was dollar beers do I buy one beer and I
turn around and she's gone I'm like what
the [ __ ] was ya looking for I'm looking
for and like did you see that blonde
cute girl dude she's out here is she's
some guy was saying outside the bar is
it yeah she just jumped in in a car some
black guy took off I'm like what the
[ __ ] do I know she's doing she's gonna
get high so I go home and I'm like you
know sitting there waiting not calling
her phone and go straight to voicemail
I'm like [ __ ] I don't know what to do so
I fall asleep on the couch
I get woke up at like four o'clock in
the morning there's two cops standing in
my living room I said hey you know what
man if Stifler yeah that's my wife like
you need to come with us
I'm like for what and they're like you
just need to come with us and I'm like
huh [ __ ] dude I already knew what it was
I'm like I'm going to identify a body
you know what I mean I already know she
ID'd you know what I mean and I'm like I
get in the back in vain and I'm just
like praying I'm like please tell me is
she okay is she okay they're like we
can't tell you anything dude I did to
the hospital dude she's [ __ ] hooked
up head to toe from [ __ ] shot tubes
down her throat and everything and
[ __ ] the cop tells me the story he's
like we got a phone call from anonymous
call that there was a nobody at a house
so we went to the house and we knocked
on the door and the people not answered
the door and there was no OD they didn't
know what the hell we were talking about
so we got back in the cruiser and we're
leaving and something told me to just
drive down the alley so it's the middle
of December there's three feet of snow
on the ground it's snowing and raining
and the cop finds her laying there in
the alley [ __ ] soaking from head to
toe
unconscious she had been there for a
half an hour blue purple she'd been and
they took her back to the guy that
dumped her and she ended up Oh Dean and
the house the guy
drug her through in the alley and put a
hoodie underneath her head in the
hoodies the only thing that saved her
life that from keeping it up out of the
snow and she had melted through three
feet of snow they threw a net and she
was all the way on the concrete so
that's how long she had been in the snow
Wow
they had hooked her up to like all these
machines trying to bring her body
temperature back and they hit her with
force too
Arkan the first three the hitter was you
should come back off one immediately
they there with another one they hit her
with another one the some had three
shots of [ __ ] narcan that they hit
her with and that doctors like she's
gone dude she's not coming back and the
nurse was like no I'm gonna do one more
shot him I'd do one more shot and
doctors like I'm writing I'm calling it
you know we're gonna call it and the
nurse pulled up another side of narcan
and hit her with it she barely came back
just just enough to start to breathe
again and name-o
resuscitate her got her to breathe and
everything like that she was she was out
of it for about two days she finally
comes to and she's like oh dude babe I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm sorry she's
like I didn't think I didn't think it
was enough dude like I went to the guy's
house I he put a little bit of a powder
on the table and was like this is my
okay stuff and I got some better stuff
that they you know he was like I got
nine days clean this would be enough so
she did a line of it and then she was
like you know what and she told me she's
like I knew what I was trying to do I
was trying ot
I was trying to kill myself because I
was so of a situation of everything
she's like they didn't do anything to me
let me give some of the good stuff she
said as soon as she did the line of the
the mediocre stuff she felt hit boom she
knew it was strong so she knew the other
stuff was you know and this is snort
initio again she snorted it she didn't
shoot it Wow she snorted lines she says
soon as she snorted that's all she did
she woke up in the hospital and then
after that she had stole a ring from
where she was working she used to clean
like mansions and stuff she stole a ring
like a twenty five thousand dollar ring
from the mayor of not minerals Toledo
his dead wife so she was cleaning the
mayor's mansion and stole his dead
wife's ring and you know he took it to
heart he did everything he could to try
to find this ring and she ended up she
came home from work that day he was like
you're not gonna believe I found a
wallet in the park and I got 700 bucks
I'm like you found a wallet in the park
where is the wallet and she's like oh I
threw it down in the park I'm like let's
go try to find him wallet cuz I didn't
believe her I knew what she did I'm like
you stole you stole some gold from works
yeah
you know previously you you know I tell
her do not steal nothing from work dude
you can't be doing that
we need that job you know what I mean it
was something you know it was bringing a
little bit of money in and then they
press charges on her and then they did a
little on sting operation where they
came and they arrested her and she went
to jail and I sat in the house by myself
for about 60 days here she did about two
months and then she finally got out and
I was clean she stayed clean for a
little bit we started smoking crack and
she left with this up it's black got it
and then come home for three weeks and I
called her and I'm like hey I got a half
a gram of crack dude if you come home
she was there [ __ ] five minutes I've
been calling her phone for three weeks
straight
she wasn't answer she wouldn't you [ __ ]
I was like hey I got a half frame you
come home on smoking with you five
minutes later she's outside are you
gonna bring that hand frame out I'm like
yeah you should honestly think I got a
[ __ ] hand for an then I'm gonna give
you right now when you show up that fast
I went nuts dude I ran out I tried to
kill him the dude in the car if they
took off they took off again together so
I went on destroying everything in a
house I broke every breakable thing in
the house I cut the couches up I cut the
bed up I took all our clothes I throw
them in the tub I don't bleach all over
them I broke every single dish every
picture I cut the rugs up I broke
everything other than the house you know
what I mean I packed all my stuff I
called her friend was like give me a
ride give me a ride back to to Michigan
I'm gonna go stay with my dad I went I
stayed with my dad I started working
with my dad I was doing pretty good and
then I ran into an old friend it was
about six months I had clean seven
months I had clean ran into my old
friend he was selling heroin
and I had you know thousands of dollars
I'd been saving up I had like five grand
on me I'm like [ __ ] it I'll do a pack I
did a pack boom I was off to the races
again I started you know ended up back
in jail living in a tent after I had got
in I got out of jail with my buddy Carl
Purdy
he uh he's dead now he killed himself
he [ __ ] we were talking about killing
herself with me I just got out of jail
and we were just so fed up with like
everything like the last five years of
my life had just been crazy you know
what I mean just absolute just nuts man
and like just death and everyone every
all my friends around me are dying and
you know it's just like I was trying to
kill myself but I never could you're not
good there wasn't enough dope in the
world that would kill me dude I would do
shots that people would be like there's
no way you're coming back from this dude
and now we're doing and it wouldn't even
get me high like I couldn't I couldn't
find death when I was when I was looking
for it I was too afraid to hang myself
too afraid to put a gun to my head but I
would I wouldn't I would put as much
heroin as I possibly could get in a rig
and shoot it up and try to die and it
wouldn't work and I I met this girl I
ended up getting clean after all that I
stayed in a tent for like three months
we me and Carl we got cleaned together
and met I met my mom my latest baby mama
Sarah I had moved the Toledo that's when
we had got them pills and we had went to
the we ended up in Florida with my mom
we were clean the whole summer
everything was cool and we just couldn't
take it no more staying out we started
sleeping in a tent because the house was
so nasty we couldn't take it
so me and sir was in a tent there was
fire ants everywhere every bite nothing
[ __ ] we're like dude we can't take this
she started her period she started our
period you
just like she was just over it's like
mom we're leaving she called their
parents and was like mom send me a
couple hundred bucks we're gonna we're
gonna come to Vegas or her parents own
nine car washes in Grants Pass Oregon a
construction company and a couple of
other businesses they were entrepreneurs
yeah they're rich rich multimillionaires
and I didn't know this I didn't know
that she came from that much money so we
pull up to this gated community in Vegas
mansions just mansions everywhere and
I'm like are you kidding me Sarah she's
like yeah this is one of my parents live
I'm like and we've been struggling this
long dude and your parents live in a
[ __ ] three-story may we come in
everything's white
you know they got Escalades in the
driveway I'm like are you kidding me
dude like she's like a baby I said I
come from money I'm like I didn't think
he came from this much money dude like
so I you know I mean I meet her parents
and everything and they're like oh well
this is what we plan to do I hate him
they hated me from the from the get-go
you know and as soon as they see me
they're like well that's not what we
expected you to look like and I'm like
what did they mean by that like I
thought maybe they thought me expected
me to look worse or I don't know I don't
know what I didn't I don't know I didn't
know how to take it but you know we're
sitting there I tell their parents my
whole life story and they start crying
you know what I mean and they're like
well we already made a decision Shane
you're getting on a plane you're going
back conditioning Sarah you're going to
Oregon and you're moving with your
sister I start bawling and I'm like if I
go back to Detroit I'm dying I'm dead
you know I mean and she's like Dan you
can't send them back to Detroit he's
gonna die you know the me and I was to
the point to like if they would have put
me on a plane I wouldn't you know I mean
it would it was I was I was so fed up I
was just like so done with struggling
and just like oh it's ready just for to
change everything in my life so I'm like
look dude please dude this is what
you've got to just loan us some money
I'm like give us $5,000 doing let us go
to Oregon let us get an apartment we'll
both get jobs and we'll pay you back and
he's like all right we'll do that
so we races
check five grand me and Sarah go to go
to Oregon we get an apartment I get a
construction job she gets a job working
at the gas station and we do it we pay
her parents back we're there for about
six months we're doing really good we've
got money in the bank we're living in a
little shitty apartment but we're
together you know what I'm saying we're
clean boom she pops up pregnant
tell us your parents that hey we're
pregnant and her parents just lose it
they're like what the [ __ ] get an
abortion now you're dumb stupidest
decision you've ever done like no you
cannot have this baby you're not
financially stable bah bah bah you know
I mean and and we're like dude who cares
you know what I'm saying we're fighting
Maria the baby's gonna be we're gonna be
fine dude you know what I mean and like
and they they come to accept it you know
and we end up you know we had our son
Noah and I I got my ID and uh the day I
got my ID dude I I went out to the bar
and I had been I've been clean for [ __ ]
almost a year now and I just wanted to
snort a line of coke so bad and I found
I was just like I I met this little
Mexican kid sitting there I started
going out and he's selling cocaine and
then him and Alex never selling cocaine
together and they're up to like selling
an ounce a week or whatever and and I've
been selling drugs since I was 15 years
old you know what I mean Hobbs and
they're making a little bit of money
Alex bought a new car Dom bought a new
car I see him I don't have a car at this
point
Sarah's driving me around everywhere I'm
like I want a car dude me and Sarah
living paycheck-to-paycheck dude I'm not
some of this money so I'll go to down
one night I go into the bar and I'm the
hey bro you need to talk to me he's like
I already knew what it was I already
knew he was messing with heroin I could
see the redness in his face any like
who's on the verge of tears do it and we
weren't even really we had known each
other we weren't like kicking it but we
were friends you know I mean I'm like
you need to come to the car and all I
wanted was a line of coke to be honest
and I'm like you need to come to the car
we went to his car and I just Morelle
along dude he didn't say a word I'm like
dude you're they
- heroin you're selling this cocaine and
I just laid it all out on duty starts
cry and he's like how the [ __ ] did you
do that even how did you just know
everything that I was going through in
life without me even telling you dude
I'm like I could see it in your eyes do
it I can I've lived it you know what I
mean he's like good at that point yet
lost everything and he was trying to
sell cocaine and get it all of that and
I'm like book new you and Alex are out
here selling cocaine you guys are dumb
and you're doing it all wrong you know
what I mean your how much are you
selling a week and he's like me and Alex
are doing like an ounce a week I'm like
how about this do it how about you front
me some cocaine do it and I'm gonna show
you how to really sell cocaine I'm gonna
sell you show you how to sell drugs any
second all right
I'm like look I'm gonna be the top dog I
just basically jumped in and
strong-armed um it took over his whole
operation I'm like I'm gonna be the
brains of the outfit and I'm gonna tell
you what to do where to do it how to do
it and you be the main guy you're that
you're the main guy you know what I mean
and so all eyes are on you so I was
calling all the shots and he's just the
front man he had the Chrysler 300 at
that time all white Chrysler 300 with
white rims and we'd all dress up in
white button-ups and a bunch of gold so
he just looked like cocaine dealers you
know and we went from him starting off
at he was doing about an ounce of meat
by the time we were up and running and
we were really flowing we we got up to
eight pounds we had at one time well we
were we worked our way up to four key it
was a lot and we do good for the [ __ ]
about a year running I'm making five
it's $10,000 a day I'm in real money so
I'm throwing wives i money at my mom and
she's like I got so much money I don't
know what to do with it I got four cars
in a driveway a motorcycle the dirt bike
we're going to the strip club and just
throwing thousands on that you know
living it up and you know me and my mom
just [ __ ] were snorting lines all night
and then I couldn't have come down I'd
be up for [ __ ] I literally I have no
septum in my nose deviated septum from
snort so much coke my nose would just
bleed
we'd hurt I'd wake up and do a grand
line wouldn't even get me high I'd do a
eight ball before it was noon you know I
mean and I'm like [ __ ] dude this dude
ain't getting me high and then so I
started shooting it I'm like start
banging coke and then I'm so high off
the coke I'm like [ __ ] I need to come
down so I [ __ ] knew this chick that
could get black I never even knew [ __ ]
and I didn't even look for heroin for
the three years that I was selling
cocaine in Grants Pass I didn't look for
it but they come down was getting so bad
from the cocaine addiction that I had I
had I had to do something so I started
doing heroin and then my cocaine sell
will start getting slower and getting
slower getting slower and getting slower
so when I'm totally focused on just
doing black and doing black and in the
beginning yeah I pull ups on my dope
man's house and throw five racks and you
know buy an ounce of heroin and then sit
in my room and my mom would come in my
room dude and just be like dude move I
would sit on my bed it would be so small
but not for me they sit on the bed dude
and just get high and get high Sarah had
left with my son and she had moved out
there's major permanent and yeah where
I'll just sit dude I have come over dude
and I wouldn't even sleep I would sleep
sit in this spot I probably set and this
spot 30 days straight and didn't leave
my eye the only time I'd leaves is to
get food and you go to the bathroom dude
and then when I would go to the bathroom
I would [ __ ] fall asleep on the
toilet and be at least fifty thousand
times over
burning a hole over the cigarette burns
everywhere it's getting Superman behind
I was doing about eight all a day and
you know in systems and I was still
sound a little bit of coke and I was
just got you know this I just went and
got this brand-new nine and somebody
called me for a ball and I and I'm like
yeah I'll serve them you know what I'm
saying it's like four o'clock in the
morning I walk outside and
like hey is that go they got five people
in the car like hey is it go good I'm
like yeah the telescope's fired man and
he's like alright cool let me check it
out so I gotta check him out you don't
like bro don't do nothing down dude I
will shoot you you know what I'm saying
and they're like go go go you know I'm
[ __ ] I just I didn't think about it
my fault my gun and I shot you no
[ __ ] put five or six rounds in the
back of the truck pop the tire popping
gas tank blew off the back window
thank God I hit nobody you know thank
God I don't hit nobody and they they all
jump off the truck
you know I'll take off running the cops
come I'm hiding in the house capstone
look at the truck trucks [ __ ] riddled
full of bullet holes so he told the
truck so they lost their truck but then
I got a reputation you know what I'm
saying in that town first
don't [ __ ] with that guy you know what I
mean he will [ __ ] shoot you and I
just I was at that point I was just
crazy dude I didn't give a [ __ ] I was
just I'd lost my second family that I
had lost my first family I went to
Oregon to do it all better to do it all
good and it still still just [ __ ] up
you know what I mean I just I couldn't
hold it together but it was the drugs
you know what I'm saying it was a fast
life it was the money it was the girls
and then that chick that I had met the
first night that had one out Rachel she
was just obsessed with me from the day
we had met and she just would come over
and come over and we'd be in here or
having a little affair you know behind
Sarah's back and how he's got a baby I
got I got her pregnant you know things
we kept it a secret from everybody knew
her everybody knew but they were so
terrified of me that they wouldn't send
nobody would Sarah's best friends knew
about me in Rachel's affair but they
wouldn't tell Sarah because I literally
threatened their life you know I would
go up to him I say if you ruin my life
and you tell Sarah about what's going on
I will [ __ ] kill you and I pull a gun
up not set it on the table and I'd be
like you ruin mine I won't ruin yours
you know
where I was because I didn't I loved
Sarah so much I did not want to lose her
but I had this [ __ ] horrible secrets
the whole time that I was and that's why
I started getting high you know what I'm
saying because I was dealing with this
and one day somebody called her that
didn't know me she had went to high
school with them but he had found out it
was like that's my friend from school
and he calls her it me and Sarah were
fighting a lot and you know what I mean
and she was never happy she was never
satisfied my my had broke up with her
boyfriend and in Florida so I said you
know what I flew her out you could come
stay with me I had a extra bedroom in
the house I'm like mom you come stay
with me so my mom she then she moved in
with us her and Sarah started butting
heads immediately and you know they just
did they didn't get along Sarah moved
out and then I ended up getting Rachel
pregnant now me and Rachel got a kid and
Sarah won't answer my phone calls she
won't you let me see no well he either
once I got out of jail this last time me
and Rachel got into it she told me to go
kill her kill myself because all I did
was ruin everybody's life and [ __ ] and
she moved to Portland blocked me on
everything so now Rachel that was
totally obsessed with me that wanted to
marry me now she hates me you know it's
now Sarah hates me now you know I mean
my sister won't let me see one of my
kids so now I'm like thought you wait I
ended up my lease is Ellen on my
apartment my ex tells my landlord about
everything about the drugs about the
raid about everything so my landlords
like I'm not signing another year lease
to you you're done you no longer on the
street we're kipper kicked out we're
living out of my car or staying at off
at the hotels and [ __ ] and I end up she
meets this guy sugar daddy and we con
them into giving us $5,000
out of money probably $100,000 in each
other yeah yeah we've we've got him out
of about a hundred grand
your father said he bought it he gave us
a lot yeah I ended up buying a new try
did oh I started selling I started just
doing weed I started shipping weed back
to Detroit and I had a really good
connect so they had mailed me like ten
thousand I'd go pick up five or six
pounds package him up and ship him back
east
I'd make five or six thousand like a
week doing that so it was some money you
know what I mean it was just a little it
was enough to Fran was still helping
Sara pay her rent and give my kids
whatever he wanted and taking her
shopping and seeing in hotels and
everything and then you know the weed
things just started to slow down a
little bit because there was it was so
dry there was no weed available you know
what I'm saying it was just let's just
go to Vegas dude no I had went to jail
and I was like a felony paper and my
homegirl she was the one that was in the
house that went to jail shot that when I
got raided I had a check that was over
and she had warrants she ended up going
to jail and then um yeah anyways she uh
she got she was in Vegas because she was
running on a delivery charge I got a
delivery a cocaine organ
she's like company I guess don't got
warrants we can't go I can't go back to
Michigan he can't go back to I can't go
back I can't go back to Oregon I can't
go back her life is done yeah he goes
back to Oregon he's going I'm going
prison and organ recipient Ohio and
smiling sirens in the city and I'm not
doing
because I'm not doing five years so what
do you guys see for your future
this right here we're just here we're
like taking it day by day
I mean I'm to the points of where I'm
just like you know what I'm gonna go
back to where I am and I'm just gonna
chop it up and I'm trying to relax I
don't want to be you know I just I miss
my son so goddamn bad I want I wanna be
in my son's life dude that's that kills
me every day you know I mean and I know
if I go back to Oregon and I get a job
and I get apartment and I'm doing good
and I stay sober Sarah's gonna let me
see my son you know what I mean if I
know I'm gonna do 22 months that's if I
go back and talk to my Pio and say hey
look this is what's going on this is
what you know this is what had happened
we had dipped out went to Vegas we come
to what we left Vegas because it was
horrible dude I absolutely hated it
there it was hot we had nowhere to go
we were sleeping in the car all day you
know and we're just struggling
struggling to put two dollars in a gas
tank to even just you know what I mean
we're trying to hustle up money on the
strip and it's just not working for us
dude were super lucky
you know we call Paul the guy that gives
us you know that sends us money and
stuff we let him on first let him on the
wall and now he's doing these burns yeah
he's done he ain't a happy no more we
get a couple hundred from them
we're throw it in the gas tank we come
here we're staying out in Santa Monica
just sleeping in the car
it's towed you know we park in the wrong
parking spot cops told the car so now
we're homeless and we ain't got nowhere
to go we are Skid Row
you know [ __ ] so yeah we're hoping I
don't know I don't know I mean we got
our G our new weekend will we're honored
every month you get food stamps I mean
like it's like right now I'm like in
limbo like I always have been I can sit
and I can it's like to be honest it's
like when I was selling and when I was
doing all this what great money comes
great responsibilities so my phone would
never stop ringing I would always have
somewhere to go and somewhere to do and
something something stressed me out
you know so I constantly be stressed out
and I would you know I'd love that
lifestyle but at the same time
that lifestyle you know what I'm saying
the money was just a side product of
that lifestyle that just time nothing
she's addicted to this type of lifestyle
she loves the streets she loves the fast
pace that running me I don't like the
dirtiness of it I don't like the for me
it's hard to you know what I'm saying I
like to have a woman you know what I'm
saying a lot like to have a girl next to
me so it's for me I haven't talked to a
girl since I left at once understand so
I got all these girls back in Oregon
calling me every day come home come home
come home we miss you and I'm stuck in
[ __ ] LA and I can't need a girl to
save my life because what I'm gonna say
oh yeah in Skid Row love my mom
you know yeah running from the [ __ ]
law from four different [ __ ] states
living in a table my mom shooting dope
you know what I mean like oh yeah I want
to come over and hang out can I stay the
night you know it don't look good unless
I'm gonna meet some other scallywag you
know girl from the streets yeah living
in a tent - it's dirtier than I am you
know I'm sandwich I've never never do
you know what I mean I can't stoop that
low unless she's an absolutely drop-dead
gorgeous and she just got here last week
you know what I'm saying
I'm like really but yeah dude it's been
a journey I think what is in my future
is I'm just gonna have to go back to
Oregon and chop it up because Orion is
home to me man Oregon is felt like no
other place I ever felt in my life
I was never accepted in Michigan dude
everywhere I went I had this last name
Stifler
so you know I all you know all her
brothers and all my family they all had
this you know this who they are you know
I'm saying oh then there's Stifler
you know they'll [ __ ] you over they'll
do this they're shady you know what I
mean so I grew up as a shady Stifler you
know what I'm saying even though I
wasn't that guy I got labeled as that
guy because of who my [ __ ] family was
so I never fit in everywhere I went oh
he's a Stifler you know I'm saying sauce
immediately I'm like I'm the outcast guy
don't trust him don't
saying no it was for me and then people
would get to know me and they do like
Stifler he's you know Shane he's a good
dude you know I'm saying like he's got
morals if he says he's gonna do
something is gonna do it you know I mean
like so I mean I have that after I'd
meet somebody for a while or hang out
with them but then I just I could never
I never had my own car at Michigan I
never had a driver's license in Michigan
I never had my own apartment in Michigan
it was until I went to Ohio right over
the line boom I had everything you know
what I mean as soon as I got out of
Michigan boom it all came to me like it
was nothing I moved to Oregon had
everything you know what I mean like I
said I've had five five fortunes and
squandered them you know beautiful homes
and cars in the driveway and money I
mean I had so much money in my safe in
Oregon I couldn't close my safe you know
oh all hunters I'm trying to close the
safe but man look at this dude huh can
you close the safest too much money in
it you know but then [ __ ] now look now
we're paying I got a doc I got one
dollar amount I got you
she's got to our on Oh we're doing
something today yeah